hi girls and guys today I'm here as you
can see here still in front of my
beautiful library and I'm going to talk
about something that I normally don't
talk about which is in this case books
that have changed my life particularly 5
top books that have made my life much
better or made my life as it is now so
without further ado let's start this is
going to be a special one I will start
with this book which is which was
written by Alan Carr this is in French
actually it's Antonia a classy guide
the original title is an easy way to
stop smoking I think some of you may be
ex members or smokers have heard about
this book I wasn't in a period of my
life in 2007 where I had everything but
I didn't have anything you know that
feeling when everything is right at its
right place but in the end inside of you
when you wake up you feel like you have
nothing well that's exactly how I felt
when I was smoking because I had been
smoking for a long time and I was really
depressed about it
and the moment I decided that I really
wanted to quit smoking then I found
myself to not being able to do that and
I was literally as my roommate would say
in panic zone so actually I don't
remember how I got hold of this book but
it just happened and then I was glad it
happened because it really changed my
life the lesson I've learned look this
is the most beautiful actually chapter
I've also put into the other it is a
montage do something about the
advantages of being a smoker there is
not one single advantage of that but the
amazing thing that I discovered is this
is a lesson I've learned from this book
is that it's a lesson for life that
don't let society brainwash you we are
all brainwashed to some degree in every
kind of field by society and actually
this book made me realize how
brainwashed I was how convinced I was
that quitting smoking was so difficult
was impossible if you think that a task
is impossible to to carry out or to
perform you're ready you know starting
not exactly on the right foot it's
actually much easier than you think you
just have to read this book if you're
still a smoker this is a piece of advice
for you and you have to believe in you
have to want to keep to quit smoking and
this is the first book the second book
that really made a difference is this
one
is written by Steven Kobe and it's
called the seven Habits of Highly
Effective People it's an amazing book
you know at the beginning I you know
about these these books about personal
growth etc etc I'm kind of a little bit
skeptical sometimes but actually this
turned out to be a really good book and
and the thing the amazing thing is that
it actually teaches you it gives you
principles this is not about just
techniques or stuff it's about
principles it's that the big lesson is
that if you abide by certain universal
principles of living your life is going
to is going to change dramatically it's
going to make a huge difference I'm
going to read this quote to you and you
see here it's a principle that all
things are created twice but not all
first creations are by conscious design
in our personal lives if we do not
develop our own self-awareness and
become responsible for first creations
we empower other people in circumstances
outside our circle of influence to shape
much of our lives by default we
reactively live the scripts handed to us
by family associates other people's
agendas the pressures or circumstance
scripts from our earlier ears from our
training from our conditioning these
scripts come from people not principals
and they rise out of your deep
vulnerabilities are deep dependency on
others and our needs for acceptance and
love for belonging for a sense of
importance and worth for a feeling that
we matter and this is really the core of
the matter we live according to
sometimes most of the time we live
according to what society dictates which
goes back to the point I was telling
before if you read this book you will
understand the core principles of the
universal principles of how we should
actually lid it's really simple
but actually most people don't follow
this really has this book has started
changing the way I see the world in the
way I interact with the world and
the world interacts with me another book
which really made a difference that I
read this year and I have to thank my
lovely roommate for that is called the
monk who sold his Ferrari by Robin
Sharma and this book is is an amazing
simple book about simple living and
living a happy life we constantly talk
about happiness what is happiness we
tend to think that happened maybe we
most of us I think myself included we
were or we are mistaken we think the
happiness sometimes we're deluded into
thinking that happiness comes from
outside from having a car a house a
beautiful Labrador a dog or like songs
etc yes this also comes from these
things but I think that happiness comes
from inside you have to fix so to say
your life step by step but and you also
like in the previous book you have to
abide by certain universal principles
I'll read you a passage here actually
it's a philosophy about life when you
adopt a deathbed mentality you live
every day as if it were your last
imagine waking up every day and asking
yourself the simple question what would
I do today if it was my last then think
about how you would treat your family
your colleagues and even those who you
don't know think about how productive
and excited you will be to live every
moment to the maximum the deathbed
question alone has the power to change
your life it will energize your days and
bring a rush of zest in spirit tool that
you do you will start focusing on all
the meaningful things that you have been
putting off and stop squandering time on
all those petty things that have dragged
you down into the quagmire of crisis and
chaos and the beautiful lesson I've
learned from this is that we all have a
purpose in life it's just up to us to
discover it we have a mission you have a
mission I have a mission maybe my
mission is to help people inspire people
to learn languages and to live a better
life through languages but you have and
I was lucky enough to find out about
maybe you haven't found out yet I like
thinking that we're also like pianos we
touch you know set certain key notes if
we do learn how to touch certain key
notes we can actually discover our
potential and how we can actually help
humanity humanity as a whole now you
have so these three books here you can
see and then I have another book which I
don't know why click on it right now a
little bit of improvisation here it's
called a miracle morning and it's there
it's just here and this is another book
that really really made a difference
because you know it's just a fantastic
book that I started reading some time
ago and let me show you the miracle
morning the not so obvious secret
guarantee to transform your life before
8:00 and by Hall or hell Harold I'm
sorry if I mispronounced his name this
is an amazing book it's all about action
it's all about do stuff to change your
life and it's a great thing I want to
read a passage from this I actually have
it on the computer which really struck
me we must realize that the real impact
and consequence of each our choice of
our choices and actions and even our
thoughts is monumental because every
single thought choice an action is
determining who we are becoming which
will ultimately determine the quality of
our lives every time you choose to do
the easy thing instead of the right
thing you're shaping your identity
becoming the type of person who does
what is easy rather than what is right
on the other hand when you do choose to
do the right thing and follow through
with your commitments especially when
you don't feel like it
you are developing the extraordinary
discipline which most people never
develop necessary for creating
extraordinary results in your life
discipline creates lifestyle and this at
the beginning you read it and you tell
yourself well yeah yeah right but then
actually when you start applying
applying this that every single moment
comes that every single thing that you
eat and every single word that you say
in every single thought that you have
has an impact on what you're going to
become this is really going
make a monumental he says difference in
your life I'd like to conclude this book
is not about personal growth
it's your literature and it's a little
bit you know a little creepy
this actually images haunted me when I
was a little kid when I was 12 I didn't
want to have this and in my room but
still this book reminds me of when I
started learning English I said it in
another video and this the lesson that
I've learned from this book when I
started reading is that don't let others
dictate what you can or you cannot do I
still remember I was in this book shop
and I was with my mother I was 12 and I
said I want that book I want to read
that book I had just started learning
English and the guy the guy you know he
just said I think this is a little bit
too difficult for this for a 12 year old
kid right and but I insisted and then I
started actually reading this with a lot
of passion and as you can see here every
time that I found a word that I didn't
know I just mark it in blue here is the
word upset I didn't know what this was
back in 1993 I think and then I actually
went through the whole book the last
thing I've learned from this apartment a
factor reading is beautiful is the fact
that you never have to give up don't let
this goes back to what I was saying
before to let others tell you what you
have to do if you want to do something
just do it I'd like to conclude this by
saying that you know I read these books
you can read reading is great but what
really makes an impact it really changes
the way actually you absorb information
is live these books lift them read
through mark them go back to them
imagine them like a guideline like a
manual in a way books contain a lot of
hidden information maybe the first time
you read you don't really understand
because you are at a certain point of
your life where this doesn't really talk
to you doesn't speak to you but then if
you read them again at certain times of
your life different intervals and you
learn how to absorb information from
books the way it is supposed to happen
and by taking action and by seeing and
by testing and once again I use the word
by living this is really going to make a
big difference in your life it doesn't
how many books you read what really
matters is that you find the books that
are right for you and you learn how to
help them make them help you become a
better person because I strongly believe
that we all have an incredible potential
you me the neighbor everybody and we
it's up to us to discover it and make it
unfold like a flower thank you for
listening and I'll talk to you very soon